[Music]
I'd like you to hear from Rosal leonetti
she's a she's a a a warrior she spoke at
my rallies uh she's smart girl politics
uh she's uh I can't thank her enough for
the work that she's done and I'm sorry
that we ran so long
Ro I have to get back to the booth Duty
downstairs um good afternoon uh my
brother-in-law Lieutenant Joseph glixon
from Red Hook ladder uh 101 was 6' three
uh Burley had a big Jolly of a laugh and
a wicked sense of humor um he was
Norwegian and Irish we continue with the
Irish
theme he married my sister uh first
generation Dominican do not call me a
racist our families join together every
September 11th Dominican Irish
together I'm going to paint a picture
for you quickly of a young Widow
standing with a t-shirt draped over her
shoulder just hours after she had
learned that the towers um had indeed
collapsed trying to smell the last
smell like mothers do if I get emotional
I don't care
a mother his mother stricken she
couldn't
move and I want to share with you my god
daughter his daughter holding my
hand as she yelled I want my daddy I
want my
daddy and she thought for a
moment he used to drive a red truck and
she thought for a moment that she saw
him and she turned
around to see who got out of the car and
it wasn't her father don't call me a
bigot don't call me a
racist memorial service was held on
November
10th
2001 empty casket 6'3 show
had only a fragment of his index finger
returned to my
sister two days
later I will share this with you my
father was so heartbroken at that
memorial service that he changed his
flight he had a vacation
planned so on November 12th his flight
went down in Bell
Harbor my
father was never also found but intact
in his shirt pocket was the
memorial card from that
service my sister had lost her husband
and her father one directly from the
attacks one indirectly this is very
personal to me the scenario of the
ground zero mosque is not a political
football we can't keep kicking it down
the line we just can't 9/11 family
members and most Americans re reject
this mosque not because we are ignorant
or Prejudice and biased individuals
because we know that the moral value of
this proposed mock does not espouse
compassion for those who still suffer
and respect for those who
died New York City is a big place and
park 51 project can be a project
anywhere it can be built
anywhere but they choose to build it
there to M to imans have been replaced
abdalah mani and in Iman F ABD and yet
they persevere and they're persistent
but we shall also persevere in
ours we are
Relentless our state department our
state department will alert us to the
threat on National Security by farri
groups yeah and they'll tell us all
about Jan Napolitano just told us two
days ago right she warned us that the
biggest threat to America in Grown
terrorist our
own so no inquiry into um where the
money for the mosque has been done by
the state department why if you have
time to go after tea party groups then
you have time to find out whether money
is being funneled for this
MOS and shortly I'm going to give you an
analogy an analogy uh well not an
analogy but I'm going to just paint for
you you know the mecca Mecca City Saudi
Arabia uh demolishing of historic
buildings in this area by the Saudi
government is seen as right too
religious uh view of the undue reverence
being given to such buildings so they'll
just tear it down don't tell me then
that where you want to build Park 51 is
not a place of reverence and you want to
come and build a cultural center no if
you can knock down your buildings in
Mecca you can certainly understand our
position here in
America and
lastly and lastly I want to say
that we are not Michael W Smith has a
song where he says that on that day evil
called itself a
martyr well evil may call itself a
martyr but Americans are resilient and
we are not going to allow disrespect to
family family members ever ever if we
have to stand there and protect that
building physically with Pam Geller
first then we will God bless you
[Applause]
uh I want to thank you I want you to
hear from one other person very
important
because yeah Ario Pantano if you could
come up here remember the viewing of the
whole movie is tomorrow it's tomorrow at
uh 11: a.m. at the Delaware the Delaware
building if you want the Delaware
building it's right next door hello it's
a ballroom and you I'm selling DVDs just
to offset the cost of the film it is a
very powerful film uh we need
politicians like alaria patana we cannot
get done but I'm telling you we have
stopped this this monster this
monstrosity so far and we will continue
to and you have to stand with me and I
know sometimes it's a lot of trouble but
you got to haul your butts up to all of
these actions it makes a difference
learn from the enemy allio that he's not
the
[Applause]
enemy
ladies thank you
the only thing that I have to say is
that your sons and your husbands and
your
brothers and your friends will never
ever be
forgotten thank
you I mean we're over and I see people
have left we're overtime but if anybody
has any questions they haven't thrown us
out yet so let's Max you know let's use
the time if anybody has any questions uh
I'm sure many of the 911 family members
would be happy to take questions yes